good evening everyone once again
hello and welcome to this webinar on
omix logic bioinformatics training
this webinar is jointly organized by
prime biotech
under the auspices of medlab congo in
nigeria
we're excited to introduce you to our
omixlogic
training programs this program will help
you see the role of big data
our next generation sequencing
technologies
in life sciences omix logic
bioinformatics training
is designed for everyone interested to
learn and apply data science skills
to study biological data sets in an
effective and meaningful way
before we get started let me introduce
you to prime bout exhibition
and team my name is adetaya
shari and i am the olympics logic
community manager for omixlogic africa
responsible for daily interaction with
hundreds of users that are part of our
bioinformatics community
managed by prime biotech
let me start by introducing pine belted
the company behind omis logic
i will share with you details about the
upcoming omics logic programs
and explain how the training resources
we will discuss today
will be used in the upcoming data
science training program
dr alfred tuber
was the one that developed this in
collaboration between bible tech
and the taba boardmatic research center
what we will discuss today
and try this program is a result of hard
work by an amazing team
led by the company co-founders doctor
alfred tubber and dr eunice bogusky
dr vertebra who comes from a medical
background as
expertise in oncology immunology and
biochemistry of inflammation
and has been recognized internationally
for its generous support of many
research projects
and initiatives that support data
science and applications
in mexico mr leonie
is the director of the toba
bioinformatics research center
at university of iphone and an expert in
both romantic science 36
he asked numerous publications in
mathematics and bioinformatics
and over the course of his career has
developed multiple novel
algorithm approaches to biomedical data
analysis
the rest of the team also includes
experts in bioinformatics computer
science and training
and some of these are amazing team
representing today
well over the course of past years our
team has been collaborating
with the number of academic
thank you very much
our team has been collaborating with a
number of academic institutions around
the world
and have participated in content
evaluation curriculum review and project
design
as a result the omixlogic programs have
been totally evaluated
and are known to lead to excellent
outcomes importantly
the programs are designed to support
students with minimal performance
background
including biology and biomedical studies
majors as well as faculty interested in
bioinformatics
data science and biomedical
research
we're excited that this event
has been laid and organized by our
dedicated team in nigeria
and india that brings together experts
who are an interest in digital research
and have all recently completed our
specialized
training what is the goal of omics logic
the goal of most logic is to provide
training in bioinformatics
to enable independent research guided by
mentors and peer
examples so to develop a growing
community with shared passion
for data-driven research an appreciation
of citizen science
and our goal is also to enable students
clinicians and faculty of all
backgrounds to develop novel and
independent research
using latest technology in life and data
sciences in this webinar our team will
introduce you to resources
that will get you started on this
journey we do hope
that you'll be able to benefit immensely
from this webinar
our objective solely is to get you
started
to introduce you to our educational
resources and the very first one would
like to talk about
is the eduti biodos info
which is important for educational
resources all you need to do
is go to this website and get signed up
let me take you on a
few seconds journey to the website
i'm sure moritz or adelaide will type
the website
link into the chat options
well edu dot c slash bio dot info
so hey you click on the register button
here you can put your username that you
love to use
on the website you can put your email
address
then after i put your email address your
answer is i'm not the robot capture
which one answered correctly you can
fill in your first name
and your last name then after that you
just click
sign up
because i've already registered let me
just log in
yeah so i've pasted the link so if you
can click on the link
uh so the screen is not shared tayo so
if you can share the
share your screen so
yeah we cannot see about
can you see now
yes okay let me take a step back then
all you need to do is type the website
name
once you oppose click on register these
are the options
you can type in your email address a
verified one
you can type in your username you can
decide on any username tap in your email
address
you have to fill this capture this i'm
not a robot capture
include your first name your last name
then click sign up
i have i'm already a member so all i
need to do is fill in my details
sort out this capture which at times
might take
one or two seconds
so that is anyone that has successfully
logged in
you can just press one into the chat box
if you have successfully logged in
so maybe if you can reload it maybe in a
different browser
yes the captcha can take some time
no sometimes it's the cache i guess so
yeah because we're using it
quite often
so my login successful now and it's
coming on now
so did you guys try it doing the same so
that we all
come to the same place and check out the
resources so we'll wait for a
for this for you to log in for a while
so please let us know that if you are
able to log in or not
so please write one if you're able to
log
in or if you have any problems let us
know
so this is the website and then you can
log in
like we like taiyo showed us just now
hello aisha did you where you able to
log in i show you there
yes
okay so okay did you were you able to
login
i'm still on it
okay sure please take your time and let
us know if you are able to log in or not
objective can you see the screen now
okay frederic thank you freddie said
he's able to log in
perfect so tayo could you show us the
profile by that time
okay
so once you're able to log in the first
thing we'd like you to do
is to update your profile this will
allow us
communicate to recognize you identify
you as a member of
our community you also advise that you
also
add us to your social media links
so for profile my profile is already
filled and from
here you can see once you opens i login
to my
account this is my full name and beside
it this is my avatar which actually
a picture before for new registrants
once you log in
go straight to the profile
out we cannot see my screen we'll click
on the profile
and from here
click on the profile again
this is how a complete
leafy profile looks like to have your
name
this is it you can edit it if you've not
added anything you can edit
and here you can add your picture
here or your avatar you can add your
full name
here this logo has to have your
social media links that that's my
linkedin account which has been added
here
this is for social links once you begin
to do courses
and finish and hem certificates the
certificate will
also show here but basically where you
can have your share links your facebook
account your
twitter account your instagram account
add them at the region of social links
once your
profile is completely filled the
community folder has a picture
or your avatar as your full name as your
social media links which will be
pretended
and as you continue in our program this
course you get as regional certificates
and attend our
webinars both the viewers and the locals
will be
be accumulated and show here so once you
do this
the next then to do is to
go to the courses page where you can
start
taking advantage of our ac close courses
some of them which are mostly free while
others are
paid
so but to fully integrate us into the
event today is one of our
mentors dr muid masunda
who has a phd
in computational biology and has over
experience
in industry and academia
i would like to answer to you now doctor
mohit
thank you very much thank you tayo
for the introduction and also for
letting us know about the
[Music]
about the registration process for the
free login
and all those things so
let me just share my screen
so um is my screen visible
[Music]
it's visible okay thank you
and i would if you could help people
mute themselves during the presentation
that would be great
okay hello everyone
my name is mohit mazumdar for everyone
who's joining for the first time
and in my current role i'm working with
students and researchers and helping
them learn about
learn and apply data science for
biological problems
so i'm really excited to be a part of
this training program as a project
mentor
so today we wanted to discuss about
bioinformatics
and so what is bioinformatics
bioinformatics is a convergence of
biology and data where both are equally
important
as well as we see what why this is
in the next few slides so
who uses bioinformatics and who is it
for
so the answer might have been statistics
statisticians computer scientists or
engineers
but the truth is that more and more
biologists
and clinicians and students are now
expected to understand
and handle their own data to publish and
succeed
in basic in both basic and translational
research
so what we have realized is that biology
itself is now rapidly acquiring the
characteristics of
data science because data management and
data generation
is becoming much and much easier now and
the focus is on
that what information what valuable
information and insight
that we can gain from the data
so this online program that we are going
to do
would be talk in which we in which we
would be talking a lot about big data
challenges and opportunities and we will
be addressing those challenges and show
you
that what we are doing to address these
uh
these upcoming uh technologies implying
this upcoming technologies
to various challenges very various
exciting
challenges using high throughput data
and high throughput technology
so uh what had happened and what have
changed in the last
few years is that the exponential growth
of data
so um
if we go to ncbi and i think many of you
are aware of ncbi on some of the
data databases that are mentioned in
this in this graph
and you can see that that during this
time
and many of the biologists and
bioinformaticians uses the
tool blast blast is a tool to do a
sequence
alignment or a sequence alignment
search for a large data sets or large
databases
that enabled us to you know do or
understand many of the comparative
analysis in bioinformatics
so starting from the time when blast
came up
from there the gene bank at ncbi people
started to you know doing
doing more and more these experiments
and one of the reason was that the
technology was getting cheaper as well
at the same time
so with the technology available and
many of these
projects were very important in the
aspect in their in the respect of
human health clinical research and also
like
other aspects of agriculture and
biotechnology
so there has been constant work from a
group
from a large group of you know
scientists researchers
industry who contributed in this uh
in this data growth so this big data
it can be described it has some
qualities
and when i am saying to you about big
data
i don't know what you are imagining and
how this is how you're
thinking about it that how how we can
visualize big data
but it's different from what what we
have been you know used to
so we have been used to working on a
single protein maybe
a group of proteins group of genes and
we were
all the time looking for our
understanding that
one uh important genes gene that we
we thought could be the cause of a
disease
so during this time we realized after
getting
like you know when this technology
evolved
and the human genome project happened so
the human genome project happened around
somewhere
um from 1993 to almost 2003
so 1990 to 2003 so this
during this time i mean we kind of
uh sequenced and annotated the human
genome project
and then we realized that
it's just not one protein or one gene
which is responsible for which is
responsible for a disease but
it's it's more complicated than that so
that's why
big data started to play or started to
play a role
in this entire research data-driven
research
and today we are going to talk more
about that uh
so after this uh current uh talking
about
the uh growth that you saw throughout
this
these years and then uh the thing that
had happened
uh with these outbreaks and we all
know very much about kobe 19 and we all
know about
uh the south cove to uh pandemic
so this pandemic has uh actually
shown this that how things have changed
over the time
and why we are now being able to you
know
gain such good insights because we are
not just
able to record the data but we are able
to also analyze the data so there's a
lot of data that
came out from this covet 90.
so today what we are going to learn um
and what we are going to understand is
about omics data
so how omix data is playing a role what
is ngs data
and how this is important for all of us
to know from a perspective of a human
being
from a perspective of a prospective of a
citizen scientist
from a perspective of a student faculty
or a researcher
so uh the phenomics
phenomics is the um you know
is the learning for learning about the
phenotypes
so we are looking at some some of the
features
that we can uh visually see and then how
we are connecting that feature
to a specific molecular event so
learning about the phenotypic
characteristics
and then uh genomics so in genomics we
are looking at the dna so we are looking
at the sequence
we are look and trying to understand
that what
is the meaning and why these certain
mutations
are so disastrous and why these certain
mutations
sometimes helped us to evolve so what is
the meaning of these
letters in the in the coding genome and
how
how can we understand and interpret uh
the locations
and the functions uh from this
technology
another important technology is
epigenomics or epigenetics which is
about the non-genetic changes
which are methylation or different types
of
different types of events histone
modification events
that have been captured from chipset
technology and another very very
important uh
omix technology is transcriptomics so
what we are learning in transcriptomics
is gene expression
so we are learning about the gene
expression the expression of certain
genes
at uh at different time points that
gives us a great insight
about what is actually happening in the
terms of what genes
what proteins are important for specific
events
we can do comparison of different events
we can look for biomarkers
so all those things are part of this
education and training that we are today
discussing
and that we all wanted you to even uh to
at least know about and be aware of
so when we talk about uh the omics
technology
how it actually uh gives us insights so
we we say a lot of things about using
omx technology
using data driven technology and then
applying them into you know this
research research project
so why how we start from a hypothesis
to a research project and when we are
talking and discussing about this
complex data and everyone is inquisite
that
what this data is many of you are maybe
beginners
so many of you have have heard about
these data types
and what they mean and what can they be
applied for
but in the end i mean all of this from a
prospective of a biologist or from
a perspective of a computer person so
in the end what we are getting is uh is
data
right so you see here in this image
uh there's a table right and the table
is showing
the data that has been obtained from one
of these experiments
so in the end it's a table uh or it's a
it's a it's a data that is not
structured but we want to make it
structured like this table
so that we can do the analysis so the
challenge here i mean i was asking you
to visualize the big data
and the challenge here is that when you
are doing
experiments such as the omics
experiments it's called the high
throughput sequencing
and the reason it's being called hydro
input sequencing because you're getting
tons of data
so you're getting data in megabytes
gigabytes terabytes
so you obviously cannot open them in
their excel sheet
so you need a computational
infrastructure to be able to
analyze that sort of data and to be able
to
interpret and apply algorithms and tools
uh data science into these sort of data
sets it's kind of it's really exciting
and it's not so difficult to learn
because uh
we kind of believe in learning from the
very beginning from the basic
so that's why we started uh this
collaborative program
and we wanted to start from the basic
and then
slowly move and grow towards the
research part and to learn
in depth and to master some of these
techniques and data analysis
so today we wanted to talk about our
upcoming program
with midlab convo and as you saw
that there's a big team out there that
is
there to support you all so we are
trying to support you all
by providing you kind of right guidance
so the omics logic programs have few
have different several components
so these different and uh components
comprises of
uh live sessions like this one so we
will have
uh live sessions for the program that
you all
should interest in and that those live
sessions will be
just a part of this entire training
because other than the live sessions
there's a lot of
stuff to look at there's a lot of
interesting things to do
and there's a lot of activity if you if
you have
if you can accommodate that sort of time
so you learn a lot from those
experiences
so what we are offering along with the
uh just the sessions
is like a lot of materials that we have
prepared for you graphical
graphical content of educational
materials
that includes videos that includes
text that includes
quizzes assignments the engagement
[Music]
of uh how to simplify how to simplify
uh the concepts and understand in a
manner
that you can apply it for research so
that's what we have been trying to do in
our complex researches
and to bring it to everyone so that we
can actually apply it in
uh in a regular basis and learn from it
so as you
so so we will just take up sorry can you
hear me now
hello tyler you there
am i audible
okay i just got disconnected i thought
so i was a as i was telling
uh everyone about the online courses uh
and the online courses are associated
with a profile so
you created a profile and i think uh
taiyo if you could please again um
write down the address web address for
the educational portal
so we just want all of you to go to the
educational portal
and uh and create your login so you will
get a login
and then and this is for everyone if you
are joining the program if you are not
joining the program you are going to
benefit it from
benefit from it because if you're not
joining the program then you'll get an
educational profile
and then you get all the free resources
and if you join the program then you get
all the paid resources
and then do the practical assignments as
well so the difference between free and
the paid resources are basically
the online sessions and the practical
assignments and the hands-on activity
so the third part of this resources that
we were talking about
is the is the t-band for platform and
the code of mixed logic platform
so we will be seeing those as well and
we will see how it is easy how
it it's easy to learn from these
platforms
and learn the um logic of the analysis
so about the program um we
kind of will be starting with an
introduction
so about the introduction i would like
to
like to know about all of you who have
joined today's session
so kind of thought we kind of thought to
do some sort of
a kind of polling so in which we can ask
uh the questions that we want to ask
from you all
and then we will know
more about all of you and then we will
discuss that how we can make it
customized
and make it more uh
focused on your ideas so i'm just
launching a poll here for everyone
so you might have been you might see a
a poll in your
in your chat in your zoom box so
please uh fill up this uh poll um
so please let us know which country you
are from
so if you can if you're from nigeria if
you're from ghana
if you're from zimbabwe if you are from
egypt
if you are from kenya or if you are from
some
other country so you can write it down
in the chat box if you are from some if
you are from other country
and uh yeah so yeah
so my country is not here as well so i
like to write others
and india yes so what is your
educational qualification that's the
second question
so if you can see that yes
so bachelor's degree are you doing like
if you're undergraduate or if you're
pursuing a bachelor's degree if you're
doing a bad uh if you're
if you're in a master's degree or if
you're doing a phd
post talk or if you're faculty or
you're interested in research or you're
doing some research in some organization
and you're a researcher so you can write
it down there as well
so once we have that we will also
discuss uh based
on based on those areas
and the third question is what is your
level of
bioinformatics knowledge so
have you uh have you done any
bioinformatics courses
before or were there any courses in your
college
did you get any chance to do some sort
of sequence
based analysis or some sort of a
project on bioinformatics so are you a
beginner
are you
are you familiar about it have you heard
about bioinformatics
do you know some concepts
okay i will end the poll maybe
in a minute or so so please take your
time and
and let us know
okay i see ajadi says uh
his registration is successful thank you
thank you jaadi and thank you eddie tayo
all right i am going to end the poll in
10 seconds
and thank you everyone for participating
in the poll
and um
and you can write uh down in the chat if
you
if you are not being able to uh if the
option is not there in the poll
so you can write it down in the chat as
well
so jackton you're saying that i'm not
audible so anytime am i audible
yes you need to work on your system
check the audio part of the system most
likely
okay thank you
yeah so okay no no i have uh two logins
so one it has audio another does not so
that's why maybe
it was showing like that okay thank you
i'm just ending the poll
and thank you all for uh
okay thank you all for uh submitting the
information
so as i was telling you that uh
that we will be covering in the first
week
when we meet when the program starts in
couple of days
we will be introducing you all to the
computational tools
and databases that are associated with
uh that are associated with the training
and that will take you to different data
types so
an introduction involves what is the
application of bioinformatics or what is
the application of omics technology
what is the application of data science
in biology
in these different domains like for
agriculture it's in
the application in agriculture if you're
interested in doing agricultural
research
and if they're at the infectious
diseases the application in infectious
diseases
the application in oncology so we are
doing all those sort of
research research programs as well
so we will be discussing you in that
session
in that during that entire week that
what is where you can apply
bioinformatics to
what all research you can do and where
are these resources that you can learn
from
and then in the end we will be having a
question and answer session
we will have we have an interactive
session where
you can ask your questions whatever your
problems that you're facing
so one of the important aspect of this
entire uh process uh this entire
time we'll be doing this for one month
would be
uh the support so you you can have all
sort of questions you can ask any basic
questions that you want to have
and just let us know and we'll be
showing you that how we can
be able to communicate with uh each
other during this program
through a through a page through our
website page
which will be a part of this program
which would be the organization page
which we'll be showing
you in some time but before that i just
wanted to tell you all that
the part of this the program uh
the first part of this program will be
about introduction
and introducing you to the several
resources that we have so we have these
three platforms
and then the sessions and also the
different data types
so the three platforms uh that we will
be working on
uh all of us uh when we start this
program
are the uh educational platform
or the portal where you saw the courses
so there we will be finding
a lot of other things uh then what
we have shown you today so introduction
to bioinformatics is a free course
so once you have are there on the site
and
and i think we have been sharing this
and
many of you have been able to log in so
please explore it when you have time
or please explore it now so the as you
in the edu t by info uh
platform you will find introduction to
bioinformatics course
so that would be the first course that
we will ask you to take
so that we there's also a form in the
end of that course that let us and
let that let us uh that let us know and
let us understand
make make us understand that how uh
you have gone through this course and
how comfortable you are with
bioinformatics after learning from
introduction to bioinformatics
so after doing that we will be doing the
hands-on exercises on server t-band for
so let me take you to the second side
uh to the server t-bind for platform and
show you
how it works
so this is the first platform and you'll
see that i have a user profile
as as i was telling you
so there is one question
i believe i am not late yet so yeah we
are also recording this
meeting and we will be we will be also
emailing you the meeting
uh this uh recorded session of this
entire
uh video of this entire session so i
think it will be
it'll be fine so if you have missed you
will catch up
so as i was telling you that this is the
first uh platform that
uh tayo showed us and and then the
second platform that i wanted to show
you all is the t by info platform
so this is the platform that you will
get access to after registration
because it in this requires uh
this is a data analysis platform that
has a lot of
a powerful platform that has a lot of
capability to do
different type of big data analysis so
in the
in our program we will be learning about
this platform
so it's a platform that is built for
built for someone who has no knowledge
or who has a very low ave
who has no background in bioinformatics
so we are kind of uh build this uh
platform thinking
in uh collaboration with our
bioinformatics research center
who built this platform to help
clinicians and researchers
to be able to do their analysis with an
ease
with a click of their mouse so i'm going
to show you how it works so there are
different sections here
and if you hover mouse you will learn
about that technology
just you just have to hover mouse and
read about it that what it is about and
what it says
so there are different sections so ngs
data type we discussed omix technology
today
so these are different ngs data types
then we have different other data types
like uh proteomics data
mass spectrum mass spectroscopy data
structural biology data
and then data integration and modeling
so not all of these
tools we will be using for for the
program because these are a lot of
research tools that are used for
different kind of problems
so we'll be exploring some sections of
this platform and one of the sections
would be transcriptomics
genomics metagenomics that i'll be
showing you
in the next slides and then we'll come
back and show you how it works in the tb
info platform so going back to the
presentation
so the first session as i was telling
you all the first session will be on
on 3rd february and will be meeting at
the same time
and the first session will include the
basics of biology
and then we will be covering the basics
of big data
and then the basics of next generation
sequencing
and the basics of all this technology
that we have been discussing in this
uh in this session so the third the
first week will be
to getting acquainted to for you to get
comfortable with this
uh with this platform and access get
access to all the platforms
and communicate with us if you have any
issues
the second week we we are going to dive
into the first technology which is
genomics
so genomics involves uh understanding
of dna right we talked about that
so how these different technologies are
helping us
understand and develop such such uh
understanding which is helpful so this
this entire spectrum and
and this and before i say more about
genomics i would like to
specifically tell you all that uh
genomics has a huge application in
clinical practice
and in patient care and also in
other applied fields as i was telling
you
so one of the major application of
genomics is in precision medicine
so the what we are learning in genomics
is the spectrum of dna variations
which in in human genome which comprises
of small base pair changes
you have heard of substitutions
insertions deletions of dna
then large genomic deletions so we will
be discussing all those
in inversions and translocations and
then
the the understanding of genomics
is is pretty much important to learn
about cancer right
because in cancer genomics cancer is
caused by
somatically acquired mutations and
it's it's a disease of genome so
yeah to learn cancer i think it's very
important to learn about the technology
uh genomics and to understand that how
those mutations are
like causing so in genomics you will
have access to
three courses introduction to genomics
we will start with introduction to
genomics which gives you a very basic
understanding of what genomics is
and then genomics one talks about these
different algorithms you can see here
a pipeline so we will talk about what a
pipeline is
but before we talk about what a pipeline
is can anyone say and tell me here
do you know what is a pipeline or what
is a what is these algorithms and this
this picture
is so
uh so the second week we will be
learning about all of that
and we will be learning about uh you
know
big data in genomics and genomic
uh genome-wide uh genetic variation
and then we will be learning about the
the example pipelines that are there so
i was telling you about pipelines
and i showed you genomics so let's go
back
let's go back to our platform and
look at the live live
example here so you here you will see
that we have
different omics data types here
transcriptomics genomics
epigenomics and then metagenomics
so in genomics we will be looking at uh
mutation variance we will be looking at
these sort of pipelines variant calling
pipeline
so what is a pipeline i asked you what
is a pipeline so let me look at the chat
and see if someone has uh
okay that's great i see some good
answers
perfect yeah those are correct answers
all of you
almost so thank you
please can someone in agree bio sciences
benefit from these training since
emphasis on biomedical uh yeah so the
emphasis
is not uh on only on biomedical but we
have
a few examples from biomedical
data data science and we have a lot of
examples from
agriculture as well so we have those
projects we have those
projects that you can look into and the
technology remains the same
so learning about the technology and
applying it to
different uh you know bioinformatics
research areas
or research areas in general so it
couldn't be
agriculture or any of those so as i was
telling you that
uh the pipeline so we are we're going
back to pipeline and
workflows so what are pipelines and
workflows let's look at one
so we have created like the topper
bioinformatics research center has
created
this amazing uh pipelines that helps us
interpret complex data with very within
with ease and also it let us learn about
the technology
it tells us in these pop-ups that
why and how to run this what this means
and if there is any associated
publication that we needed to run that
we needed to
learn or you know read
so you kind of uh in a demo pipeline
what we have done is that we have uh
used a
publication based data set that we go
through
so in a demonstration pipeline we will
be together learning this and doing this
together
and you will be getting also video video
lectures
to do and to learn to do how to know and
learn how to do this
so we will be sending you the the
courses is here you'll have
access to the courses which are hands-on
courses on genomics
which describes these pipelines and then
we will be sending you the video
tutorials
in addition to that we will also have
sessions
so this hybrid interactive program omix
logic programs
concludes includes of all those all
those components which i was telling you
so genomics would be the second week so
we will be doing genomics in the second
week
and then we will be doing transcr sorry
then we will be
moving to metagenomics so the second
week will be about
metagenomics okay so do you guys
uh can anyone tell me or uh if if
if any of you can tell tell us that do
you have interest in metagenomics
any of you have you heard of it
or have you thought of it ever like
what is metagenomics and where it can be
applied and what is going on
in this new field it's a new field uh
so please let us know in the chat chat
have you heard of this metagenomics
analysis microbiome metagenome
it has a lot of application in and we
are also doing a
specialized program that i'll show you
on metagenomics but this session and
this
this week is dedicated for metagenomics
okay valentina thank you for telling us
and dobie also
so valentina you're interested in
metagenomics so this week we will be
going through
metagenomics and some of the
projects that are there uh as a data set
for learning meta genomics american got
my gut
project is one of such project so to
those who are interested in learning
about metagenomics
yes this program includes uh
metagenomics
as well
so to learn about metagenomics we will
discuss about micro what microbiome is
how we can use next generation
sequencing to study whole microbial
communities and analyze individual
microbial
microbial microbial genomes and we will
also discuss data sets that are
available for analysis of study of role
of
microbes play in what what role microbes
play in agriculture
what role microbes play in biomedical
research
and epidemiological studies of
infectious diseases
so microbes has a lot of application in
today's world
and in this session we will be learning
about you know
uh microbiome composition and taxonomy
uh so in uh if if i say
if i tell you about metagenomics
metagenomics
is the fee it's refers to both research
technique
and also a research field so it can be
defined as a genomic analysis of
microbial dna from environmental
communities
so culture free sequencing so
that's one of the biggest advantage of
metagenomics so
in this we will be learning about
metagenomic data analysis and you will
have access to
these three courses metagen introduction
to metagenomics
metagenomics and metagenomics too so
they cover from a wide range of meta
genomics
research so anyone who has a focused
interest on metagenomics
they can totally jump into the second
week themselves from the very beginning
so if you're just interested in genomics
you can focus on genomics if you're
interested
in metagenomics you can focus on
metagenomics and you can reach out to us
for any problems or any questions
that you have that you wanted to clarify
about so this program would be about
that
and then after this metagenomics session
we have
which is on 17th february as i was
telling you that we'll be doing
16s and hypervariable regions learning
about those
studying ngs gut microbiota and how it
relates to human health
those are all covered in the in the
metagenomics
courses and one of the biggest uh
uh you know advantage of this would be
that
many of it would be depend on
if it would be on you to do so you will
have
you'll have your own time to do this at
at a time that is more convenient for
you because
these will be emailed to you and you
will have access to the platforms
for one month 24 7. so it depends when
you take out your time
and you you can learn from these
resources
because they will be available for you
all the time during this
one month period when you're registered
so the last week would be
on about transcriptomics very important
uh
technology and i think it's it's widely
used for
biomedical research and also for
clinical research and agricultural
research
when we are where we are identifying
potential
uh like highly expressed and low
expressed genes in different forms
so we are sort of doing a lot of
comparison so it could be a mutant
versus
a wild type mutation comparison for
agricultural stuff so we have had a lot
of projects
where we used this sort of comparison
for uh tomato and also we have a project
on
crop drought and
and there is this one on potato
so we have a lot of projects that
explains the
the cancer biology and biomarkers how we
can identify biomarkers
by using transcriptomics so this is i
think a great opportunity to learn about
different omics technology
within one month or maybe you can expand
it to two to
three months it depends on you so if you
are
wanted to focus on a specific technology
you can learn it for one month and then
then uh extend your subscription for
second month and learn about another
technology
or if you have time then i would
recommend you to go through all of them
that includes the courses so in
transcriptomics
we have transcriptomics one two and
three uh
which you will be in which you will be
learning from the
introduction to rna-seq
to applying rna-seq how data science and
machine learning is being
used to apply at rna-seq so we have this
session on 24th
and we will be meeting and discussing
transcriptomics and then as i was
telling you that
a lot of it is not only to learn but
also to apply
so in transcriptomics 3 we will be
learning about machine learning
and how machine learning is used uh
by applying them so it will be all of it
would be hands-on
so from data to different techniques
to different algorithms to different uh
languages so that's the last part of
today's presentation
so i'm going to take you to the to the
platform again
and i am going to ask you all that if
you have any questions
please let us know or let me know
and we can we can actually answer this
question and answer
so i see that a lot of people are
sharing their email addresses
okay thank you tayo for asking
about the metagenomics so we also have a
dedicated program
just up for metagenomics that would be
starting on 16 february and we'll be
sharing you the details
and this would be a really uh program
for metagenomics research
so that would be really a cool thing for
you to check out
so we'll be showing you that but before
that i just wanted to show you that
uh that how this entire training will be
conducted
using these resources these cloud
resources that anyone can take
so transcriptomics i told you that we
will be covering transcriptomics
and data science so we have these four
projects on transcriptomics that
you can learn from already and
then we have this data science section
data mining section where we have
supervised
and unsupervised analysis so this
supervised analysis you will see that
there are
different algorithms that are applied to
these sort of databases like random
forest
these are machine learning algorithms
svm support vector machine
regression and then and then
discriminate discrimination analysis
linear discrimination analysis and their
different versions and then this thing
so there are different
supervised analysis that are that we can
perform on the data
and also unsupervised like pca
clustering if you have
ever heard of these and k means these
are used
for many other data sets elsewhere not
only in biology
but also in finance and all those other
techniques uh sorry other data data sets
so uh we will be learning from here
and and then we have the courses so i
have been
uh back and forth telling you that that
this
entire process is quite simple because
you have tutorials to look at and then
you have a place to
do your experiments so this is how
we are going to cover those uh two
aspects
and once you get familiarized with all
of this and if you have an interest
in python nr so can you tell me
in the chat do you have interest in
python and our learning about
programming or coding
are you guys interested in coding any of
you
okay fatima is interested in learning r
ruby is also interested in learning r
miriam is interested mansour is
interested
prince is also interested so okay thank
you guys for letting us know
clement is also interested so next i'm
going to show you that
how uh how the omix technology
and uh the
coding and coding in bioinformatics what
we are doing
and what how it is done
so we have uh created a platform just
for you
i mean people for those biologists and
bioinformaticians
and and students who does not have a
background
to learn coding so coding for
bioinformatics so this is not
hardcore coding about r and python so i
just want to tell you that
there are a lot of free courses and
there are a lot of good courses also
which are available
to learn just coding
so this is not about learning just
coding
it it is about applying coding to
bioinformatics
apply and do coding for these sort of
data sets that we discussed
so these data sets when we are working
on them and when we are running those
statistics and algorithms
in the end what we are getting we are
getting some
results that we want to visually see
right we want to see them
in a graph we want to see them how they
look
uh and how we can find a pattern
from the data right so those sort of
things
are really uh one of the best features
of these two algorithm programming and
coding languages
which are r and python so what we have
created
is this code or mixed logic platform so
let us all go to this platform
and
taiyo can you share it let me also try
and share the
share the link and sunny
if you can share the kodamix logic link
so this platform is also free so you can
go
there go here and take free courses so
there are a lot of free courses
that you can take from and learn from
here and
if you're a part of the program then you
will also get some
uh premium courses uh
not sure about the process but
you can go to code.omicslogic.com
i'm just pasting the link here okay the
thing is pasted
thank you so much uh yeah so
you can go to the coding platform and
get started for free
so you can create a login right now here
so
if you are there in this if you have
reached here
let me know
so if you are not logged in it will look
like this it will be look
it you will look at like this
yeah so there will be no courses here
and if you see the difference
here you will have courses here
so once you log in you will see the
courses
and let's check out the courses
so the courses are uh are in a form
which uh which has code blocks so all
these
uh all these courses will have code
blocks where you can
run your own code so you don't need to
install python and art to your computer
if you don't have a powerful computer or
if you don't have like a
device uh so you can do it from the
browser so this entire course can be
done through a browser
and you can learn uh about all the ngs
technologies you can learn about
coding so let me show you how it is done
so getting started with bioinformatics
it's a free course
so the one that have star are the
premium courses
so it starts with loading data in r so
just the very uh first thing that you
wanted to do
so once uh we start this program we will
be sending
everyone the detail how to do this like
how to login to these different
uh three uh different platforms to the
participants who are joining
and we will be sending them more
detailed tutorials to do this on their
own also so that they can
look at it as a guide and do this by
their own
so here you will be able to see
that
okay so adequately if you can mute
yourself
please
okay thank you
okay thank you so as i was telling you
that it has different
sections the first section is to
understand the problem
so we kind of explains what the this
this this problem section is what is
this defined
then describes the code so what is the
code you can read about the code
details here what it contains and then
you can download the data
which uses this code and then you can
upload this code
into this uh into this platform which
will come
next so after learning you you know what
is
it and what is it is going to do then
you
try it yourself so here you can
you have a code block that you can try
yourself
and then you can run this code and then
you can generate
different uh files and i'm not going to
do a demonstration right now because
we're running out of time
but it's free and you can all uh
try this up so i will recommend you to
go to this
website and try this free coding lessons
and
if you join then let us know we'll be
able to help you more with this
so this is the coding
okay so one of the things uh in the end
that i wanted to add
is that how would we know that what what
are you doing
because it's an online program we are
not sitting with you we are not knowing
that
uh how much you have learned so what
what do we do how do we know that how
much you learn
so we know by looking at the activity
so all the activity that you do all the
learning that you do
on the three platforms you can see your
performance you can see how much you
have finished the courses
everything is there in your profile so
it let you know
that how much you have learned it let us
know how much
as a group you guys have to learn so we
can see that
you can see for example here there are
sessions and there are projects
so this is the activity on three
platforms of all the users during this
time
what they have done and what how much
they have learned so for this course
completion
we expect every one of you to get at
least three hundred point uh three
thousand points
in one month so the point system is
does work with the number of courses
like you finish
all the activity that you do and
also like get a profile so for here you
can see an example like once you finish
the courses
once you complete some of the tasks
which are like running the
uh finishing the assignment and stuff
you will get points
and then you will be able to learn from
those
to next to the projects that how it is
applied to the projects
and we have had like uh the this
previous program that we did
in september in october so we have had a
lot of
reviews and feedbacks that we got from
uh participants especially
from lagos and especially from um
lead city and other uh nearby cities
there
and uh we got a lot of students who who
really
uh went through the entire exercise
and actually achieved a lot so we have
had several students who came from
different backgrounds
so not just biology or microbiology but
different backgrounds
and they were able to do uh finish these
courses
and learn from it so the background and
the
other problems that they had were
much uh were solved and they were really
happy about this training
that what they have learned
so uh as i was telling you that how do
you apply this into a real research so
we have a
ongoing program today we had the first
session
uh the second session sorry about in
this program about this program which is
the infectious disease program
where we are learning and applying this
technology especially for infectious
diseases
so we are just working on corona
research kovit 19 research
ebola research tuberculosis and malaria
research
and the group especially that we are
working in with in ghana
is uh nuguchi memorial institute for
medical research um nmi
mr and there we have a group of
scientists
who have interest in their uh in
bioinformatics and they wanted to
do this for vaccine research they are
doing it for
drug repurposing and they are looking at
population level data so we are
working together in collaboration with
them and many of
the students who are in who are
interested in infectious diseases
phd students or faculty those who wanted
to do this sort of research and have
some sort of either grants or do they do
have some
financial support
they joined our program for this so this
program has started and if you
any of you are interested in learning
more about this program
please reach out to us uh please reach
out to
uh africa at the rate pine dot bio so
tayo if you can just put
put that your email address and
you can also reach out for us for the
metagenomics program
and i saw that many of you have shared
the metagenomics
program details that you are interested
in so this one
is going to start from 16th uh february
and all of our programs uh
these research programs uh have an
option of
uh scholarships so you can obviously
apply for scholarships as well because
these are
programs that would require you to have
a research license
and upload data and do those analysis
so i welcome you all to join any of
these programs
but i think it's great if you have
if you're a beginner to start with this
meta this
program that we discussed today on basic
bioinformatics basic omics logic
uh in collaboration with met lab convo
and our team
at uh in in nigeria
so i would like to now pass it on to um
tayo to discuss a little bit more about
what his practical experience has been
and how we have been supporting together
this initiative
hello thank you very much
thank you for the wonderful expose
well presently we there's also another
introductory
class on basic homes logic
and from our own experience from this
end the
prior biotech mixed logic program is a
well-structured well-organized geology
programs
for beginners for people who are novel
who have no
prior information or prior ideas about
bioinformatics whether as
students researchers asking insurance
i'm from a clinical background i'm
actually a dentist
and with bible tech platforms and
educational resources
thank you tayo and uh i have been able
to get grounded
will not have one before joining kali
amazon
program of course we do have the
instincts courses on the external
platform on the education
we have suggested we have employed we
have employed you to join
we do have the introductory courses
there but aside that the pipelines the
coding platform and the virtual lessons
are majorly practical hands-on programs
this is not a program where you only
come here to listen to the tutorial and
listen to
courses you at each program
there will be particular hands-on that
will expose you to
either coding or to either the server t
bio dot info pipeline where you can run
analysis you can
visualize your sequence visualize your
read and visualize mutation pipelines
likewise that you can also do the same
thing with metagenomics and
microbiome data so i
will advise you to log in and
avail yourself of this opportunity and i
know the income
this even though this is one under the
auspices or
middle combo with aisha dollar and
emmanuel
i'm sure you have the best answers and
the best mentors both locally
through the med lab convo team also
through the
old mixed logic nigerian team an
internationally true
uh international team led by elia botsky
with the ceo
and we also have dr pete core who has a
phd we also have dr mazonda who was
who has been discussing with us since
the beginning of his webinar so it is
this is this is an opportunity
to really log into to to explore
cutting-edge research technologies
to lend data analysis to land of
informatics and to be able
to help you forge ahead in your research
in your postgraduate studies you know
undergraduate
discipline i will join every one of you
too please
log in and avail yourself
of this immense opportunity and i'm sure
you
you're not going to regret it this is
something that can cut apart your
career or your graduate studies
you you definitely definitely have
testimonies
afterwards please join us as we
build an amazing community
of life science citizen scientists
who are looking globally the the the
globe the corner virus pandemic has
opened
our highs and heres to the average
to the immense opportunities in genomic
studies
in the multi-mixed integration studies
and this program will not only introduce
it to them
it will also guide you step by step on
how to become grounded
in bioinformatics and life sciences so
please join us and you
you will have testimonies
at the end of the program and it's not a
one-time program i'm sure men love congo
and other
partners in the romantic program are
planning a series of programs so that is
not only that will make you a beginner
also take you through because i'm sure
you also have intermediate courses
advanced courses so that not only will
you let us is a continuum
it's not a one-time thing it's a
continuum where you learn
where you're grounded and by the end of
this series you will be able
by yourself be able to run these
pipelines and do
these research projects two publication
stages and
at any point in time you have mentors to
guide you through all the stages
so once again thank you for joining us
today and i'm sure
you'll be part of this novel
unprecedented
or well established community thank you
thank you everyone
thank you everyone and thank you for
joining today's session
and uh we also have aisha so aisha do
you want to say a few words
and conclude the session
okay i am maisha adela from
madlab congress nigeria and it's been
a wonderful session and i hope
we the everyone that's participated and
joined
have really gained a lot and we look
forward to having everyone enroll for
the
courses and apply them into
various aspects of their field thank you
very much everyone
really appreciate you thank you everyone
and we will see you soon have a nice day
take care bye
you